hi there steve here again and uh once
again i'm going to talk about language
learning if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe
if you find this one useful please give
it a like
um today i want to talk about
noticing in language learning
now you've probably heard me say that
the three keys to language learning are
your attitude in other words
uh are you interested in the language do
you think you can do it um
are you um you know confident you can do
it um
do you think the method you're using is
gonna work all these attitude things are
extremely important
the second one is
oh and i should add on the attitude side
uh you have to be prepared to deal with
uh frustration uncertainty and so forth
uh the second one is time of course you
have to put in a lot of time we can't
learn overnight
and then the third one is the ability to
notice and a lot of people don't
understand what is meant by that
furthermore uh the idea that noticing is
an important part of language learning
is challenged in academic circles
challenged even by my great mentor
stephen krashen
so the reason i'm talking about this
today is that i noticed noticed
that in my turkish learning
that i seem to be going through sort of
a
an evolution in my ability to absorb
turkish so
initially in going through my mini
stories
really all i was doing was accumulating
vocabulary and i wasn't really paying
much attention to
the tenses
and
languages are a lot of them quite
redundant so you don't always have to
have the pronoun or you don't
necessarily always have to have all the
words or understand the grammar
in order to get a sense of what the
story is about by the same token if you
are using this content these stories for
language acquisition you can also deal
with the story being a little bit
less than clear
and that can be even true when i was
reading you know russian novels like
anna karenina and not really having a
good grasp of russian cases i was
sometimes not really clear as to who was
doing what to whom
but i'm accumulating words and and at
the same time accumulating sort of a
sense of the language
but now when i listen to these stories
for the umpteenth time or read them for
the umpteenth time
i find that i'm starting to concentrate
more on tenses
part of that was printing out
long lists of uh you know tenses in
turkish
reading through them once twice three
times four times not really
being able to remember anything
but it just made me that little bit more
attentive to the issue of tenses and so
now when i read these same stories where
i have the words i know it's
you know eat run say do
now i pay attention to whether it's will
run or did run and i
i start to see these patterns better i
start to notice
some aspects of the grammar better there
are other aspects that i'm still not
kind of comfortable with and the
noticing is is not just recognizing what
the tense is but also
starting to feel as if that structure
has that meaning
so you know for example if you see uh
the n ending in turkish it's like
apostrophe s that starts to become
natural so that the evolution is i pick
up a lot of vocabulary then i start to
notice certain things
either because i've seen them so often
or because i looked it up
or someone corrected me but for whatever
reason i start to notice these things
then i pay more attention to those
things
and i think that there is a natural
evolution there i think
in our brains we are our brains from an
evolutionary perspective are best at
sort of
sorting out patterns
based on a lot of stimulus
we are not quite as good at theoretical
explanations
uh we're not very good at block learning
tables
however some of these explanations and
some of these tables cause us to pay
more attention to some parts of the
language
and then we start to notice certain
things better and that helps us then
we notice them when we read i watch it
you know a
turkish movie on netflix and i noticed
something there again so that
it's a bit to me it's like
you know it's like a jigsaw puzzle when
you first start a jigsaw puzzle you got
nothing but as you start to put the
pieces together you start to notice
where some of these other pieces might
fit and i think the language learning is
like that it's an evolutionary
perspective
but obviously things that help you pay
attention to
some aspects of structure of
grammar and stuff help you notice if you
notice something
then you are more likely to to associate
that structure with
the tense or with other aspects you know
functional
meaning in a sentence so i think that
that noticing is important but if you
google
noticing in language learning you'll see
that there's a tremendous dispute
amongst
learned people in language acquisition
um i have to admit that i'm very
skeptical
of a lot of the research into language
acquisition although i have read
lots of books on the subject i have lots
of books here on the subject
but i think that that a lot of the you
know rather than these books on language
acquisition i prefer this book
on how the brain learns because i think
the learning of language is not so
different from learning other things
and the problem with a lot of the
research on language acquisition it's is
based on the the assumption that
learning takes place in a classroom so
that
whenever they do studies they study
learners in a classroom
i haven't
seen any studies where they deal
strictly with
independent language learners or people
who learn just
you know incidentally because they're in
a an environment where the language is
spoken sort of that non-formal
acquisition of languages crashing comes
closest to that because he points out
quite correctly in my view that the
most important thing is listening and
reading
you know just input
meaningful comprehensible hopefully
eventually compelling input lots of it i
don't know what my statistics are
uh in turkish i should have looked them
up but i'm sure i'm over 50 60 hours of
listening and however 50 60 000 words of
reading
there was a brief i had a brief twitter
exchange with someone who said that i
think someone asked what is the worst
advice you've ever gotten on language
learning and someone said well one was
to totally depend on grammar and the
other one was don't speak until you're
ready and i said why is that bad advice
i speak when i feel like speaking when i
feel i'm ready or i should add when i
have the opportunity like if i'm
learning turkish or farsi and i see
someone who looks like they might be
speaker of that language i'll try and
use it but otherwise i don't worry about
speaking i speak when i'm ready and then
this person came back and said no the
average person is
you know a perfectionist or is timid or
is reluctant
my experience is that if you have
acquired a strong level of comprehension
in the language
listening and reading you understand
what you hear
then the likelihood is that that person
is going to start speaking with
difficulty at first
if they have really good comprehension
skills because the biggest i think fear
people have is that they won't
understand what is said back to them but
if they have very good comprehension
skills the words and phrases are
bubbling in your mind you i think the
natural tendencies to want to try to use
them so i i think a lot of people
who study in the traditional sort of
language class where they are forced to
speak actually they don't end up
speaking that well and if they would put
more emphasis
on acquisition on on input on listening
and reading and developing that ability
to notice wanting to notice uh allowing
different things you know at different
times you notice different things
the first
many passes through my many stories i'm
just
noticing words and acquiring words but
after a while i start to be more curious
about these different forms and then i
start to notice the past tense the
future tense and i think later on i'll
notice some other aspects of turkish so
that the the ability to notice develops
gradually and there are a number of
things that contribute to it but it is
an important part of acquiring the
language thank you for listening bye for
now